hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
my name is Adam today we are back
playing hitman and it's time for another
elusive target so we are going to try
and get through this once with a silent
assassin rating we have special
parameters in place with this one we
must murder two surgeons using a
hemorrhagic infection so therefore we
have to locate the weapon of death and
then use it on both characters and not
get spotted at all let's give this a go
authentic ready for this
we are going to start off in the
operating theater but make sure you
bring your modern emetic syringe but not
the other one your modern emetic syringe
other than that we just need coins we're
going to be throwing a few coins around
right then if you can skip this scene do
so as soon as this doctor goes past you
jump out of blending in and crack it out
this door around to the right next
you're going to go down to the morgue
that's where the syringes are held so
downstairs there are a couple people
down here to be aware of but we'll look
at that in a moment hit our left and in
this room here just on the right hand
side are both syringes if you pick up
one you pick up both so don't worry
about dusters next we're going to take
out the camera systems you can either do
that by getting your gun out here and
shooting across the room or I prefer to
do it by hand so make sure you crouch
when you run past anyone just to be
ultra safe and take out the evidence
next retrace your steps run past the
Kill Bill reference and back to where
the two morgue doctors are looking at a
dead body try stay crouched when you're
running past these gentlemen it makes it
much easier right now you can really peg
it we're going to run all the way to the
sushi restaurant
as we addressed as a doctor all the
doors are open to us okay once you've
come upstairs right here's an important
point there's a random element to this
the doctor you're looking for does it
look like he's he yeah oh there he is
there is that's the doctor we're looking
for if he isn't going outside at this
point if he is on his iPad or if he's
sipping wine or if he's eating sushi
I recommend restarting so to do that
press options and restart or press pause
and restart depending on what formats
you are on I really recommend restarting
if that's the case because waiting may
take 10 minutes depending on what he
does anyway once he starts walking
outside you will need your coins we're
gonna throw it over there and hopefully
if the thrown it right I have nice
bounced off the rock and it's gone right
in front of his feet Hey okay so we'll
try again or throw another one in that
corner rather nothing and once he starts
going over to the coin make sure you
pick the correct syringe we want the
hemorrhagic syringe not the modern
syringe okay it's really important
because we want to kill him outright not
send him to the toilet okay once he's
down I'm gonna fix my contact I really
like them drag him a little bit he's
pretty much died in a good area there
I'm just gonna drag him over a little
tiny bit just to make sure no one spots
this body and then we are just going to
run all the way back and retrace our
steps
so quite boring this part so through the
sushi restaurant
nice hat dome Liddy back downstairs
through the locked door and pretty much
all the way back to the Marg
oops sorry
wrong way right duck down like usual to
run past these gentlemen and back
through to the left and up these stairs
and we're pretty much back where we
started now if we are lucky there will
be a girl just on the left which we need
to take out are we are not lucky which
means she's probably still in the
operating theater are somewhere on this
corridor if we were quicker we could
have taken her out already and we could
have been on for world record time but
we've missed our opportunity so it's a
case of finding there she is finding her
and what she is going to do once she's
gone to do a little bit of work she's
going to come back down this corridor
and she's going to stand in this corner
and take a phone call
while she's doing that we are going to
stick her with a syringe we are not
going to use the hemorrhagic syringe at
that point we are going to use the
modern emetic syringe I know this is
getting quite complex and it wasn't
plumbed this way basically this one will
make her need the bathroom extremely
quickly like always here she is so she's
coming over and she's going to make that
phone call very soon so I'll try
distract her with a door in the meantime
right so while she's making this phone
call you'll notice there's a few guards
around the one of the corridor and this
one on the right who's just gone to the
bathroom as well we have to make sure
when we stick her with this no one can
see
it's me I know what dr. fidon't told you
we'll keep an eye on the guards as soon
as there is an opening we will take it
if for some reason this this doesn't
work for you she does walk through this
room that we are stood in there is an
extra opportunity to stick her with the
syringe but we'll see what happens so we
just need this one guard on the
right-hand side to bugger off and then
we're gonna try and get round the back
of it without nudging her
and sadly attack her with the emetic
poison and we'll peg it off to the
bathroom just in case she thinks it's us
so I shall feel a bit ill now social
grasp her stomach come on love be
quicker than this here she comes right
she will pick she will pick which
restroom she prefers we will get our
poison syringe ready and we will stick
her with it
thought it that easy oh I've just
noticed there's actually a window here
to make a skip even easier so we don't
even have to go back through the complex
just jump straight out to this window
and make your way over to the helicopter
no one suspects a thing and that's as
easy as it is so there is a random
element to this with that gentleman if
he is drinking wine or reading his iPad
restart that is my suggestion to you but
if you want to play all in one go you
may be there for another 10 minutes but
you'll get there you will get there you
don't have to restart anyway it's all
about that white you cooter yukata the
white yukata we've managed to get it so
that's the last thing I was personally
after and let's see it's out no sassoon
that's not the cracking most cracking
time we could have knocked four minutes
off that if we were quicker but that
doesn't matter it's all about the silent
assassin rating so we should be top 20
maybe in the world which will probably
drop to about 50 soon 19th that's okay
anyway I imagine from PlayStation
grenade do as a favor and give us a like
and maybe subscribe I'll see you next